bulls albert sono ancora con la voce
allora prova a parlare un attimo è
normale per farvi capire bene a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti miss è fissata la
voce allora posso bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovissimo video sono
pa vj e oggi ho la voce un po più
pizzata del solito meno male ma non sono
ancora al cento per cento quindi parlerò
un po con la voce un po più bassina
samsung con gol thing significa andato a
giocare a golf
ok hanno fatto anche mary golf plus gold
mer egon phishing e va bene sono quattro
horror regione ma a golf in goggi che
comunque dal gioco dal titolo il gioco
non sembra ma lo è così cod
grazie non si apre la porta c'è un pesce
non vedo cosa ci sia di sa dove sono le
palline posso chiedere qui si gioca a
golf senza pallina e chiedo per un amico
non c'è la palla manca la palla la palla
eccola qua 3 2 1 come faccio colpi come
si colpisce a 9 sto male mi ha fatto
benissimo
draghi ha fatto benissimo perché c'è un
pesce in mano mentre gioca a golf santo
iddio alla stretta che è difficilissimo
non l'abbiamo ragazze trattato troppo
bene madonna è un casino aspetta ma dai
attenzione proprio lui non saltata
qualcuna di buca o giusto no eccola qua
la 2 attenzione non solo proprio fatto
per giocare a golf
ne siete accorti o questa buona ok detto
qua ma è esattamente l'oro dove time vi
prendono per il culo
e allora e 32 tiri in tutte e 13 le
buche io ho fatto 32 tiri in due buche
ansia aperta la porta di prima al lecce
e molto strano questo circolo di golf
però entriamo
beh perfetto mi sembra siamo un attimo
torna dietro c'è un attimo un problema
di tipo e nascondere e non circolo di
golf di minigolf
tra l'altro mi sembra un po eccessivo ma
equa che ci sono le buche da golf dove
c'è questa trappola per orsi ma è lo
schivata se l'hai presa so cazzi tuoi
trovato o c'è un tasto sul muro faccio
una leva che manca da trovare una leva
pure salve buongiorno buon gioia ho
visto un tizio che era una pallina da
golf con una mazza in mano passare non
sono pazzo ve lo giuro l'ho visto l'ho
visto e non vado dove c'è lui vado
dall'altra parte perché c'è un tizio
veramente brutto che cosa cazzo ho visto
ragazzi
ok ok c'era qualcuno c'era qualcuno
facciamo finta di niente facciamo finta
di niente ecco l'altra leva perfetto
vado a prendere l'altra leva vado a
mettere l'altra leva a meno a meno che
una pallina da golf non decida che io
debba morire
cosa che potrebbe succedere visto che
questo gioco è comunque un horror
questa è una trappola che posso usarla
anche contro di lui o lei so se è un
maschio o una femmina so solo che ha una
palla ed eccoci tornati al punto di
vantaggio dov'è finito cioè se posso
chiedere che sarà messa a correre qua
dentro ma è sparito completamente è
veramente inquietante signori che io
debba fare questa cosa sapendo che c'è
una pallina che gira ma non lo non l'ho
più vista
croce sparito chi conto di dio
ride pure ma che roba è
ma questa una buca
no ragazzi aiuto questa è una buca che
cazzo non fare io qua sempre attaccata
al muro definire pazzesco ok grazie
grazie a tutti sono fatto 5
mi spieghi che cosa cazzo sei scherzo si
aperta sia aperta 77 77 tutti uniti da
porta a porta a portà la portava portò
la portò la proposta fatta volta bastava
ti aiuterà programma le salve davvero so
chi sei
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto dopo sarà il
collare una voce cosa faccio
no per favore non migliori fare buche ma
la verità non me ne devo rifare per
forti per chi te lo chiedo per cortesia
o chiedo re found è aperta vabbè si è
aperta ma lascia aperta fa col cazzo che
poi queste chiusa nessuno si può andare
finché mio premio non è sul muro o il
regno che premio ma questo al pesce lo
portare il pe il pesce lo devo mettere
il pesce perché se no non posso uscire
quindi prendo il pesce prendo il pesce
frase un po ambigua però avete che
aprendo questo pesce qua dove capita io
erano i pesci questi pesci l'altro ci
sarà uno più grosso degli altri perché
comunque è un premio tipo questo è un
pesce più grosso 62 occhi quindi
immagino che sia questo prendo questo io
veramente non so cosa mi sto facendo
della mia vita di merda arrivederci
questo è il premio della vita lo metto
qua un momento qua perfetto arrivederci
a è stato bello eh
e stato bello che gioco strano ok ok
siamo tornati nella parte bella
sostanzialmente la vita una merda va
bene va bene quindi adesso mi devo
giocare le buche con ma poi è orribile
c'è la cosa più brutta che io abbia mai
visto
ci vedo giocare a golf con questo rigira
sembra un po un'esagerazione ma dai
e vabbè ma non fosse jowga ma scusami ma
henan si accende come gioco io non si
può giocare parte fatto che non mi molla
cioè non mi molla c'è lui faccio non mi
molla lo zio con dove vado ammazza
ammazza
se muoio faccio perché tanto non mi
molla cioè devo farmi tutte le buche
così ma siamo matti
diciamo che siamo [ __ ] vabbè ma
e questo è tornato indietro ma sotto la
di due ore porca [ __ ] e dove vado
dove vado
ci sono acer quale altra terza buca qua
ti prego come l'affare sua sorella morta
l'altra palla o che veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce no vero dai
nice nice nice l'ho fatta l'ho fatta
l'omessa la messa la messa la messa la
parata gigio donnarumma dove la prendo
vela porta dove la porta a porta qua qua
perfetto pesci pesci cresci nice
allora io conclude reliqua ragazzi ma
solo perché sto perdendo la voce cinque
ragazzi mandati parecchio avanti anche
se qua vedo dei tentacoli e cose poco
normali però vabbè nonché il resto del
gioco fosse normale pero che vi do vi
sia piaciuto gli schede ai cani mi
dispiace volevo c un po così ma in
questi giorni non ho voce quindi questa
cosa e un bacino uccidiamo vinto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]